moyens danièle obono il ya aussi ugo
bernalicis qui est dans la dans la
commission et il ya l'ensemble des
partis de l'assemblée nationale qui sont
qui sont représentés dans cette mission
et c'est assez unanimes globalement on a
pas de divergence majeure aujourd'hui
sur on partait en partait pas avec des
idées reçues mais mais toutes les
auditions qu'on a pu mener que ce soit
des médecins que ce soit des policiers
que ce soit différent
on a regardé les expériences étrangères
aussi parce qu'on sait que aujourd'hui
il ya plus de dix états aux états unis
qu'en légalisé il ya le canada qui a
légalisé il ya l'uruguay et qu'elle
égaliser donc ça ça bouge beaucoup à
travers le monde et même en europe sur
la partie thérapeutique et ses bd on est
a aujourd'hui 22 pays sur 27 qui ont
évolué sur cette législation là et la
france restent totalement la traîne un
des cinq derniers pays à n'avoir pas
bougé sur les deux autres partis intègre
dans les états où ils ont autorisé le
cannabis une explosion des accidents vos
lectures mais une diminution de la
consommation voiture mais sans la
consommation chez les jeunes ya
énormément d'éléments contradictoires
dans ce débat on va les examiner
évidemment les uns après les autres mais
cette évolution autorisé cette évolution
des parlementaires français vous la
mettez sur le compte d'une meilleure
observation de ce qui s'est passé à
l'étranger essentiellement et puis les
parlementaires ils sont le reflet de la
société je pense que au niveau de la
société ça a considérablement évolué et
je pense qu'il en avait une majorité il
ya quelques années contre cette
égalisation et je pense que ça s'est
inversé et que ça terriblement et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on en appelle
d'ailleurs dans cette mission à une
consultation populaire sur une
convention citoyenne de son un
référendum sur ce sujet là parce que je
pense que là dessus la société même
peut-être sans doute plus en avance que
le monde politique on voit bien que en
situations d'échec la lâcheté c'est de
rester dans la situation dans laquelle
on est aujourd'hui où nos gamins peuvent
trouver du cannabis à tous les coins de
rue enfin c'est pas d'hier d'ailleurs à
moi n'est donc donc faire respecter la
loi du coude entérine cette faiblesse
est en incapacité de faire respecter la
loi on l'entérinent en autorisant
quelque chose qui devrait il va falloir
s'y retrouver dans ma bouche de
policiers pour courir après 900
mills ont fait terminer d'abord je
voudrais te dire je voudrais mais c'est
intéressant de la manière dont 1 mais je
comprends très bien maintenant je
voudrais dire que si c'est un référendum
je souhaite bien du courage parce que
dans notre mini référendum voyez c'est à
peu près du 50 50
donc ça va être très chaud je voudrais
simplement avant que chacun présente ses
arguments que vous nous disiez les
principaux arguments que vous retenez en
faveur de cette légalisation pourquoi
vous êtes en faveur de la légalisation
du cannabis un sous titre d'abord un
souci de santé publique
un souci de santé publique parce
qu'aujourd'hui comme jeudi nos gamins
sont exposés au cannabis et avec des
taux de thc qui sont plus en plus
important en plus et on sait que sur des
cerveaux en formation la légalisation ne
veut pas dire on autorise tout et
n'importe quoi il faut un encadrement
c'est assez dangereux c'est une drogue
comme l'alcool comme le tabac et il faut
le réguler il faut l'interdire aux
mineurs parce que sur des cerveaux en
formation et jusqu'à 21 ans on estime à
peu près des taux de thc très important
un peuvent avoir des effets
catastrophiques en cas d un usage
quotidien et achetez donc c'est la
substance légalisant vous êtes persuadé
que vous avez réglé le problème
détrompez-vous et est sûr c'est que
c'est qu'avec la peau émission l'a pas
réglé je vous laisse lâchez vos chevaux
on n'a pas rappelé une situation
française un peu paradoxal c'est qu'en
effet nous avons le record d'europe de
consommation la législation la plus
répressive la liste ça sent la peur est
perçue maison il ya quelque chose qui ne
marche pas donc déjà alors il ya deux
mois ce qui était bouillant dès le début
des débats il ya deux mois je serais
favorable à la légalisation si c'était
extrêmement encadré ci voulait pour des
raison élémentaire sire que si
j'apprends qu'un adolescent un enfant a
accès au cannabis évidemment je me
révolte
immédiatement il faut quand même dire
aux jeunes qu'ils nous regardent
je veux pas faire de démagogie mais que
les conséquences je ne suis pas médecin
mais j'ai eu autour de moi des
adolescents qui ont pris longtemps du
cannabis et je vois la manière dont le
cannabis a ravagé leur cerveau les pros
des troubles de mémoire des dépressions
des épisodes schizophrénique réel et
parfois de bipolarité qui se sont en
tout cas un peu amplifié à cause du
cannabis et des gens qui avaient à
l'avenir devant eux
écoutez un coup on sont devenus
une sorte de d'épaves à rester chez eux
toute la journée
refusant d'aller au cinéma au théâtre ou
au musée étant pressé de retourner dans
leurs cahutes pour fumer je trouve ça
catastrophique
maintenant il est vrai qu'un adulte
consentant pour des raisons
thérapeutiques extra peut très bien les
chaque finaliste mais et la houle et le
vie s'installe c'est que je me suis
vraiment documenter avant de faire cette
émission pour le défendre ou pour le
contrer les études médicales possède une
petite ambiguïté c'est à dire que les
liens de causalité qu'on veuille
défendre le cannabis ou qu'on veuille le
conspuer les liens de causalité ne sont
jamais établi c'est toujours une
causalité faible par exemple est-ce que
ça enclenche des dépressions la
causalité n'est pas prouvée est-ce que
ça aggrave les cancers la causalité
n'est pas pauvre ou est-ce que ça a
déclenché des troubles de la conscience
s'est pas complètement prouve et
inversement
est-ce que ça fait vraiment du bien en
termes de chimiothérapie la causalité
n'est pas complètement pouvait est ce
que ça peut résoudre des problèmes de de
sommeil la causalité n'est pas
complètement faux mélanger tous les
socialistes dont on parle du du cannabis
récréatif et bien essentiellement là que
j'ai bien compris mais ça allait quand
même faire une petite après ce que
j'aime bien faire dans cette émission
c'est qu'un mot puisse quand même être
définies avant l'émission parce qu'après
on parle là je sors le cannabis il est
clair le mot ces drogues le cannabis
c'est de la drogue
le cannabis récréatif est terminée que
chacun puisse éclairer les chocolats en
quelques mots le cannabis récréatif a
ceci de gravissime à mon avis que
d'abord aujourd'hui il est consommé par
eux parce qu'on consomme anton semble de
subversion donc la subversion par
rapport au cannabis elle me paraît quand
même véniel la subversion par rapport à
la cocaïne ou l'héroïne qui vont se
substituer
à au cannabis une fois que le cannabis
sera autorisée en motifs de subversion
ils vont prendre la place pas simplement
pour les trafiquants mais aussi en
termes de subversion ils vont prendre la
place
la dangerosité ont prêté au cannabis ça
va être immédiatement remplacé par le la
cocaïne ou l'héroïne
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose eric c'est de voir quand même les
dégâts que ça fait en terme d'accidents
de la route et c'est un corps et donc je
ne comprends pas pourquoi on fait on
légalise la drogue au prétexte et vous
venez de vous trahir monsieur le député
au prétexte que précisément on est
incapable de mettre fin à un trafic
il en fallait donc on entérine
exactement comme les salles de shoot on
entérine une impuissance politique par
une sorte de légalisme qui est en fait
un légalisme sénat mais c'est un
argument de choses ni moi d'abord que
vous avez un peu mélangé tous les noms
j'en tous les aspects du cannabis il ya
une expérimentation sur le cannabis
thérapeutique qui va commencer le mois
prochain pour deux sur trois mille
personnes pendant deux ans donc
on